a subset of the Internet of Things is a
whole category of medical devices we
have wearables things like the Fitbit we
have embeddable zwi have implantable as
things like diabetic pumps for example
internet-enabled defibrillators
implanted in our chest so implantable
defibrillators pacemakers and the like
we have brain computer interface and now
we're even creating pills that are
internet enabled so that you can swallow
a pill goes into your stomach the pills
computer is powered by your stomach acid
and it can control the leap the release
of medicine how much medicine is
released over time so we are slowly but
surely becoming cyborgs I know it sounds
like science fiction but if you think
about it most people are walking around
with our cell phone in their pocket or
in their hand 24-7 when people go to
sleep they put it on their ninth on
their nightstand so slowly but surely
computers are replacing our own
cognitive abilities to an extent when I
was younger I used to know by memory the
phone numbers of all of my friends
because there were no cell phones with
all these little address bugs today we
just automatically dump that data into
our cell phone and just call it up on
demand the same with our address book
and like so that cell phone though
currently outside of our body means
that's kind of the first step towards us
theoretical theoretically becoming
cyborgs the next step of course will be
implanting these devices into us there
are people several researchers including
one out of Cambridge in the UK that have
implanted RFID chips underneath our skin
for years these people are called body
modders and they will go out there and
use those RFID chips to open up the
security door in their office place to
pay for goods and services so you can
actually do that now so there's a whole
movement of people who are quite
interested it's sort of underground
these days it's if you it's sort of the
next generation of piercing right
there's a whole community around
piercing and tattooing and the next
generation that is to implant these can
puter devices in our skin under our skin
that give us new forms of senses for
example magnets whole movement of people
put magnets under their skin and they
have now created a sixth sense that the
rest of us don't have which is that they
can actually explore magnetism in our
environment so for the more computers
that we put in there is no special
exemption for medical devices that makes
them unhappy belen fact medical devices
are entirely hackable going back four or
five years the Medtronic pacemaker the
automatic defibrillator was proven by
the University of Massachusetts Amherst
to be hackable we're remotely you could
go ahead and deliver a shock to
somebody's heart to somebody's perfectly
functioning heart a shock that would
cause a well-functioning heart to go
into cardiac arrest at the defcon and
black conferences and hacker conferences
in Las Vegas we've had hackers on stage
exploit these devices one famously done
with a Bluetooth cannon basically a
Bluetooth extender that could allow
somebody from a distance of a few
hundred feet find people who had
diabetic pumps right these are pumps
inside their bodies that feed insulin on
a very controlled basis into the human
body and with this Bluetooth cannon you
could take a few weeks of insulin and
release it in an hour causing somebody
to go into a diabetic coma and therefore
death so these tools are clearly going
to save right hundreds of thousands of
live there are hundreds of thousands of
implanted medical devices in human
beings in the United States and around
the world today that number is going to
grow exponentially as they become more
powerful brain computer interface
computers such as cochlear implants are
growing in the old days if you were
hearing impaired they would kind of
create a hearing aid that you'd war
inside your ear now they can actually
attach a device directly to your skull
and wire it into your auditory nerve
directly into your brain so there is an
interface between a computer on your
body and your brain via the auditory
nerve and it's controlled again via
bluetooth so think about this the
Bluetooth hacks are incredibly easy to
carry out there are many many known
exploits you can download apps that will
do Bluetooth exploits and so if
somebody's wearing this type of hearing
aid I could subvert that I could make
sounds and noise into their auditory
nerve via hac that nobody else would
hear i could make them think that
they're going crazy right you can do all
different types of terrible things and
you may be thinking why would somebody
do this right only a truly sick person
would do this and I'm sad to say there
are some people like that in this world
I go back five or six years to a case
that I site in the book from the
national epilepsy foundation for people
who may not be aware epileptics have to
guard themselves against sudden bright
flashing lights that can cause them to
go into grand mal seizures and somebody
five or six years ago hack the national
epilepsy foundation website and so when
epileptics went to their website for
information rather than seeing the
epilepsy foundations webpage what they
saw was a bunch of flash code blinking
blinking blinking really fast in their
eyes and several cases of grand mal
seizures were recorded as a result of
that hack so unfortunately there are
some people in this world who do things
like that and our mothers for no other
reason than for the kicks of it all